a bra gun holster an electromagnet plus
balls equals
wah-ha-ha-ha Vsauce Kevin here
this is mindflow touchscreens are okay
how about touching a force field using
infrared sensors this multi-touch system
allows a traditional monitor to be
manipulated by hand and can also be
suspended in air to control a screen
from afar
bosses can spy on their workers from
afar with this telepresence balloon this
floating blimp shows a projection of a
person's face it's controlled remotely
and broadcasts audio through a built-in
speaker if that wasn't weird enough just
hug a robot Telenoid is another
telepresence device except it has facial
expressions transmitted from the user
through a webcam and facial recognition
software and don't worry there's a
handheld version
bipedal robots are usually heavy and
unstable but Kermit here can hop and
that giant arm isn't being used to aid
in the jumping even though it looks like
humans can hop higher with the BOGO Pogo
a redesigned pogo stick featuring a bow
assist an aircraft grade aluminum here's
an audio-video illusion the McGurk
effect is a perceptual phenomenon which
causes your vision to over match your
hearing
the man says Bob but your eyes see Bob
so you end up hearing ba ba ba ba ba ba
[Music]
good now it's time for a giant crossbow
slingshot this thing shoots six steel
balls simultaneously to thrash
watermelon and wood boards to learn how
to MacGyver things for yourself check
out Mac recipes a website dedicated to
every macgyverism I'm still not sure how
we turn that coffin into a jet ski I'm
also not sure how this helps you play
basketball but apparently a French team
seems to think that it works converse
made a huge mirror out of Chuck Taylors
that works by mapping the users
movements and spinning the sneakers
breakfast is said to be the most
important meal of the day so here it is
floating in slow motion
but you might prefer eating 10 pounds of
gummy bears that reenact your favorite
classic video games like breakout and
pac-man finally here's a reel of epic
animatronics from John Nolan
[Music]
there was a greenhouse inside the
greenhouse there was a white house
inside the White House there was a red
house inside the red house there were a
lot of babies what is it and now for the
genius of the week there are four video
game references in this video and
there's one at facebook.com slash Vsauce
gaming find all five video game
references and leave your answer in the
comments below the first person to do so
correctly will be our genius of the week
good luck and as always thanks for
watching
you